hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on foreigner again and
today as Thursday it is dive stream
recap day but it's also April 25th the
release day of the reveal of season 10
now season 10 is not live that'll be
going live May 2nd but this is the
reveal to show off all the stuff coming
in season 10 so we have lots to get in
through we have the hero improvements
the new character soccer Oh some info
some weapons some armor all this
beautiful stuff happening as well as a
new map so as always like divet if you
do enjoy subscribe before new I covered
the informational site a foreigner that
being the balance changes the hero
updates the patch notes and the leaks so
if you want to be kept up today with
everything happening within the world of
foreigner and never miss out or not they
never stay subscribe the channel my
Twitter in discord will be in the
description down below if you guys want
to follow and join those I highly
recommend it and let's get started with
the news for today so first up is the
new map it's called the canopy it's a
samurai temple and it looks absolutely
beautiful they always make these Maps
incredibly well done so can't big
congrats they are team they are
absolutely amazing and what they do and
it reminds me of an already present map
in the game but I keep forgetting it
there's like a bridge that you can knock
people off of it was in an arcade mode a
lot I keep forgetting the name someone
can definitely tell me in the comments
below and also kinda reminds me of the
campaign mission where you play as the
Orochi and you have to throw a bunch of
poison traps so it's kind of a mix
between both of those and honestly it
looks like really cool and I definitely
cannot wait to play it the only issue is
that it is only playable in tribute duel
brawl skirmish and elimination so will
not be able to play in Dominion which is
kind of sad and it does seem pretty
small judging from the trailer and it
does seem kind of small just just seeing
the thing in general but it is a forest
in like a tree house setting let loads
of bridges and many vantage points to
come across so I think it's gonna be
really cool lots of drop-down attacks
coming in a lot of people getting hit
from out of nowhere from these drop-down
attacks all these different people and
different ledges and levels of the map
fighting it's gonna look really cool
probably lots of legend considering the
fact that these bridges lead at the
bottom of the bridges there's nothing
it's just unplayable area so most likely
will be some ledge games coming on with
that one yeah but let me know what you
guys think about the map like I said
there's gonna be lots of legend
potential I assume from this tribute
it's gonna be able to play in this
people that do like duel and brawl such
as myself although I do prefer a little
bit of Dominion from here and there can
of course play that like I said I'm
really upset the Dominion isn't part of
this but it's okay
I still think the map is really well
done the
our team did an amazing job at this and
the fact that we keep changing all these
sceneries and that it's in a tree house
is really really cool I've always been a
big fan of having these really cool up
in high places type areas and it kind of
reminds me of that one map with a huge
tower that has the tribute mode so it's
gonna be similar to that I cannot wait
to see if people do this I'm assuming
that multiple drop down attacks plunging
attacks are gonna come from this but
yeah I definitely let me know what you
guys think about this map in the
comments below whether you think it's
cool it's garbage or anything like that
I'd love to hear your thoughts down in
the comments below and with that let's
continue on with the rest of the video
next up we have the hito kiri or Sakura
showcase now first off they started with
the design and kind of how they wanted
to get the character and when they make
characters they always want to start
with a story and then follow up with the
weapon this weapon in case being the
masa carry axe if you want to know more
about the character I made a lore video
on hee Tokyo or Sakura and yesterday's
video so if you want to see some
backstory character the origin story you
could check the I on the top right
coming up right about now and that will
take you to that lore video where we
discover everything that I could have
found out about the character and some
other stuff like that the developers
also talked about this within the dev
stream about their about the lore for
the backstory and I basically nailed it
so I'm really happy about that so that
is some solid info coming from that
video and a quick tip before we get into
the gameplay her ornaments are gonna be
placed on our arms just like bored ogre
so definitely keep that in mind but that
will be covered in a later video
you'll understand by the end of this one
but first up they showed the gameplay of
hito kiri so Sakura has a stance called
Mugen rule or Mugen ryu and this can be
initiated from a light or heavy it's not
like Shaolin or where a Highlander where
they go into an actual different stance
where you have to hold the attack button
or something like that but it's
basically a chain she can combo together
moves like a kick sweep another heavier
like or even an unblockable heavy with
this new stance so for example one combo
could be light attack into heavy heavy
into uninterruptible light light in to
kick or light into sweep or heavy into
sweep stuff like that it doesn't
actually say that these are chains but
you can chain them together along for
lots of mix-ups most of these moves do
have hyper armor and cancel most of
these like the sweep and the unblockable
heavy her standard lights do about 18
damage with the Heavy's doing about 30
from the start and a teamfight she's
definitely well suited for 4 viewers as
an aggressive heavy she plays very
similar tissue goki except that she
could put a lot more
on the character as opposed to shougo
key even with the current rework as for
dual she might be able to keep up but it
can be a little bit tougher than usual
I'm assuming by the day you know the day
that she releases she's gonna be an
absolute powerhouse but I'm assuming by
after a couple weeks people will start
to get to understand her as a character
she also has infinite heavy chain and
you can end it with a uninterruptible
light to end that chain her light
starters and light finishers also have
hyper armor so you can trade and not be
hit mid combo to keep up that pressure
and like I said before her lights are
uninterruptible it's not your standard
light attack where when you when they
block the light it stops the combo you
can keep pushing through it
the kick is very normal very similar to
Centurion except this one guarantees a
heavy attack which is about 30 damage
charging the kick turns into a sweet
blue lines for a light finisher so about
18 damage you can also cancel her sweep
into a guard break if needed for this
certain scenario she also has a dodge
forward heavy and a quick 1/2 zone which
has lots of forward movement involvement
allowing you to close the gap in the
opponent and she doesn't have a huge
move set but I've judged it just judging
from this it seems like her mix ups can
be useful very well even if she has a
small move set they also went over her
feats not do keep in mind that this is
not every single feat that she has some
of these are probably refeeds from kept
past characters but they are gonna be
showing her some of the original feats
that she does have within the game and
honestly these are pretty cool
so the first feat they didn't actually
specify name so I do apologize so the
first feat is when executing an opponent
you get a shield and super armor so she
cannot be blocked from doing an
execution which means you can go into
the middle of the B Lane on Dominion and
the minions will have nothing to do with
her and she could just keep doing her
execution not have to worry about
getting it shut down from the minions or
any other players nearby they of course
gave her the shield because even
obviously you can't be knocked out of
this execution so you need some little
extra health just in case so that's why
they gave her that for the second feat
it marks an opponent and if the opponent
is executed by you or anyone on your
team everyone nearby that opponent will
get extra health for her third feat when
executing she gets a 30% damage
resistance after executing an opponent
and this can last until she dies and for
the final fourth feat which is a little
bit controversial in my opinion it is
basically a 200 damage feet that can
one-hit just about every single
character in the game I'm not really
sure how I feel about this but I have to
admit it looks really cool in terms of
an
but the only way that you won't be able
to you the only way that you'll be able
to actually live through this as if you
possibly have revenge a damage debuff on
her or anything like that so it's a lot
of different stipulations but most of
the time you will be getting one shot by
this move and that's why it is a tear
for feet now remember those are gonna be
her default so be aware that there is
gonna be more to show for her when the
game actually can't win season 10
actually comes out and as most of her
stuff is really about execution so if
you're big on executions and you like
feats you should definitely do that and
even if you are playing a sir you really
need to keep in mind that you need to
get these executions so that you can be
a lot more powerful within the match
next up was the armor and ended up
showing the heat so kiri or Sakura armor
so that's really nice to see and just
judging from the base outfits of what
they've been showing it the armor is
going to look absolutely magnificent and
I cannot wait to wear the same game lots
of variations within the helmet coming
from this character some with a mask and
some without which is nice to see for
people who enjoy having a faceless
character and stuff which I do
personally prefer some have wood masks
some also have some leather to really
bring out the customization so everyone
can enjoy every type of this character
with whatever customization they choose
there's even an executioner mask which
goes really really well with the
character seeing as this is an
executioner as as an assassin type
character especially because the feats
happen to revolve around executing so I
think that's gonna fit really well with
the lore of the character I'm personally
gonna be wearing the big hairy helmet
once I get it because this really
reminds me of the lorax from dr. Seuss
and I don't know why I got I chuckle out
of this helmet but it's kind of comical
so I'm definitely to try to wear that
especially because I can see the face
and I'm not gonna lie the character face
them face models for both characters
yato and sakura look absolutely supreme
the colors as you can tell are pretty
bland and dry but they aren't normally
this way you will have to be able to pop
them out if you're playing as the
attacker and defending when you're doing
4v4 modes like Dominion so there will be
a lot more brighter colors if you're
more into that but if you want to do
some duals and you don't really like the
pop-out colors then you can of course
have that dry blend look for that more
nitty-gritty realistic feel which is
what I personally like as well and of
course the reason they put the ornaments
on the shoulders I had a few people ask
me this in the comment sections and they
never really said an answer but they
finally gave us an answer as to why they
put the ornaments on the shoulder so
that we can now have a lot they can now
have a lot more creative freedom when it
comes to the helmets and making the
designs look a lot crazier like the ones
I've
on screen so it's always nice to see
personally I do like that the ornaments
are on the shoulders it can really buff
out the shoulders and the pauldrons make
those look a lot cooler and then the
helmets can be a really freaky design as
I stated before then go over any weapons
which is kind of sad I don't know if
that's gonna be later in the stream
because as I'm recording this I'm like
halfway through the stream because
they're gonna be showing some exhibition
games and I don't want to just be seeing
there I want to put out content as quick
as I can for you guys so if there is
weapons I will cover those later in the
future for the video so definitely be on
the lookout for that yeah guys that's
gonna be the end hopefully you guys did
enjoy like the video if you did as I
stated like two seconds ago I will have
a couple videos out later we still have
to get to the hero improvements part in
terms of reworks we also have to cover
the customization the new weapons coming
for season 10 so that we be on the
lookout for those videos and like the
next hour - what that like to be if you
do enjoy a subscriber for new I cover
the informational side a foreigner that
being the balance changes the hero
updates the patch notes and the leaks so
if we want to be kept up to date with
everything happening within the world of
foreigner and never miss out on an
update definitely stay subscribe to the
channel by Twitter and discord will be
in the description down below if you
guys want to join those I will highly
appreciate that and with that guys take
care be on the lookout for my future
videos and enjoy it
[Music]